I had lunch at the Beverly Hills Friars
Club many years ago I think this was in
the 80s in California and the Friars
Club was an all-male club founded by
celebrities founded by Milton Berle who
was called mr. television in his time he
was the most important comic and
television to entertainer and the best
known that there ever was and that's
when television first came into
existence so I had lunch there and then
I approached Milton Berle after I'd
spoken to some other members there about
being a member and I said I would like
to become a member of the Friars Club
and he said well why do you want to
become a member of the Friars Club and I
said well mr. Berle of course because
you have a great cobb salad and he said
oh really he said don't you know it's an
all men's club and I said oh really and
he said but I think you knew that he
said I'll tell you what I'm going to do
not only am I going to make the motion
for you to become a member but i am
going to second my own motion he said
you think it's because you're a woman
wrong is to lower the average age of the
club because the average age of the club
is dead and with that I became the first
woman member of the Friars Club by the
way I had first been asked by some
members who might approached would I be
an honorary member instead of a regular
member and I said no it will be a
dishonor to be a member of a club that
discriminates I wanted to be a full dues
paying member with all the rights and
privileges of any other members so
that's how I became a member then after
that of course I had a little hassle
with them over the fact that they
wouldn't let me use the health club
because the men were going in there
naked into the steam room and I said
well look i'm paying the same dues as
anyone else i have to have same rights
and privileges to use the club as anyone
else i said here you're off
you can put your clothes on you can have
me and other women go in there with no
clothes on you can have even separate
hours for men and women if you wish as
long as they're equal hours but we have
to be able to use the health club well
they had their meetings and talked about
it and really wouldn't do anything so I
filed a complaint with the State
Franchise Tax Board to take away their
tax deduction for members of the club
that got their attention and they said
okay well you can come in and use the
steam room but we're not going to put
our clothes on I said I don't really
care about your naked butts I just care
about the naked truth so I'm going to go
in so I dressed in a gay 90's bathing
suit it took in a tape measure knocked
on the door of the steam room and walked
in with a tape measure singing peggy
lee's is that all there is is that all
there is with that the towels were
whipped around the men's butts and i
became the first woman member to ever
use the steam room and it was opened up
to women after that